des dissertations j'en ai écrit pas mal
un vrai aristote
j'en ai écrit tout d'abord pour préparer
et passer les concours puis pour le site
mais l'idée de culture générale et
commente même parfois en vidéo vous
pouvez recevoir quelques unes en
cliquant sur le lien dans la description
et en me laissant votre adresse email
pour que je vous les envoie au total
j'écris entre 20 et 30 dissertation
parents et à force j'ai remarqué que
certains mots reviennent vraiment
souvent je suis romain lui c'est
aristote
enfin bon j'aurais pu le présenter avant
voici donc aristote avec un h
je suis romain et vous êtes sûr mais
l'idée de culture générale
[Musique]
je vais donc vous donner la liste des
vains mots qui sont selon moi les plus
importants en dissertation
est ce que tu peux aboyer pour donner le
top départ il ya encore du travail
niveau dressage le mot problème n'est
pas forcément beaucoup utilisé mais il
est quand même important
il a surtout sa place dans
l'introduction on peut écrire par
exemple le problème et consiste dans
mais aussi possiblement dans les
transitions pour prendre un peu de recul
et dire où en est la réflexion
si je dis qu'il est important c'est
parce qu'il montre qu'on a bien
conscience du fait que l'exercice de la
dissertation
eh bien ça consiste fondamentalement
résoudre un problème intellectuel
d'ailleurs le mot problème est la racine
de termes fondamentaux du vocabulaire de
la méthodologie de la dissertation comme
problématique problématiser ou encore
problématisation qui des problèmes 10
questions l'adjectif interrogatif
qu'elle il sert comme le nom l'indiqué à
poser des questions c'est pour ça qu'il
est surtout utile à la fin de la
problématisation qui est généralement
l'asu partie finale d'une introduction
ou pour formuler la problématique de la
dissertation pour le sujet de philo la
philosophie c'est apprendre à mourir que
je prends reprendre et souvent en
exemple dans cette vidéo pour ce sujet
vous pourrez par exemple se demander
très simplement dans l'introduction
quel est le lien entre la philosophie et
la mort les questions de ce genre
elles servent à mettre en évidence le
problème du sujet de la dissertation et
à le découper en sous problème
[Musique]
un peu comme le mot problème le nom
commun et non c est assez peu utilisées
alors qu'il a une vraie valeur ajoutée
évoquer explicitement les noms c'est ça
montre qu'on est pragmatique condé
focalisés sur la résolution du problème
précis du sujet jusque dans le détail
des mots ce mot est donc un signal de
pertinence et ce signal peut être
produit dans l'introduction la
conclusion les introduction et
conclusion partielle est dans les
transitions bref à tous les endroits où
il est question de l'évolution générale
de la réflexion bon là c'est assez
évident le verbe définirait le nom
commun définition servent pour définir
les termes du sujet dans l'introduction
et éventuellement dans le développement
s'il faut définir un nouveau terme
les profs leur ai fait le répète
beaucoup qu'il faut définir les termes
du sujet est pourtant c'est parfois
oubliés est souvent négligée c'est une
étape cruciale parce que le processus
intellectuel à l'oeuvre dans la
dissertation est totalement dépendante
du langage qui est le logiciel de
l'intelligence humaine disserter sans
définir les termes du sujet c'est un peu
comme vouloir utiliser un ordinateur
sans logiciel
je ne suis pas un expert en informatique
mais ça me semble compliqué on a pas mal
de préjugés sur les chihuahuas par
exemple qu'ils auraient forcément le
poids là ce n'est pas toujours 20 en
philo en culture générale et dans une
moindre mesure en histoire et grandes
économies par exemple la dissertation
sert à vérifier
voire à dépasser ce qui est communément
admis sur la question
du coup le mot préjugés peut s'avérer
utile surtout dans la problématisation
pour le sujet la philosophie c'est
apprendre à mourir par exemple j'écrirai
bien dans l'introduction
le préjugé modernes semblent considérer
la philosophie comme une chance ou même
au même titre que l'histoire par exemple
ou la littérature
le préjugé est grosso modo c'est qu'on
me considère pas mal la philosophie
comme une matière scolaire de nos jours
alors qu'elle était beaucoup plus que ça
dans l'antiquité on pourrait aussi
parler de lieux communs opinion doxa
sentiment prévalant impression mentalité
etc
[Musique]
ce moi aussi est relativement peu
utilisé dans les dissertations mais il
est important sur le fond c'est vrai que
j'utilise peut-être plus souvent des
alternatives comme dimension versant
portée et c'est ce que ces termes
représenter la nécessité de décrire les
différents aspects du problème à
résoudre
on peut par exemple dire explicitement
que le problème a une dimension sociale
ou économique
une portée politique plus généralement
la description des aspects du problème
est souvent comme dessus comme la
première étape de la réflexion comme le
prouve le bien commode plan aspect
causes conséquences
je ferai une vidéo sur les plans de
dissertation donc
abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de sa sortie
comme le disait rousseau pour résoudre
un problème on n'a pas le choix il faut
en identifier les causes mais bon le mot
cause faire peu sec pas très littéraire
donc les correcteurs lui préfère
généralement le non comme un facteur
on peut aussi parler de fondement
d'origine de source et éventuellement de
principe
ces mots se retrouve surtout dans la
problématisation ou dans la formulation
du plan dans un sujet sur la
mondialisation par exemple il faudrait
s'interroger sur les facteurs du
phénomène facteurs techniques ou
technologiques juridiques économiques
etc
[Musique]
ici comme pour le mot précédent effet a
surtout sa place dans la
problématisation et dans la formulation
du plan si on utilise un plan aspect
causes conséquences plutôt bateau sur le
sujet de la mondialisation
alors on fera une troisième partie qui
traite des effets ou des conséquences de
la mondialisation les alternatives de ce
beau son conséquence incidence produits
fruits aboutissement etc
ces mots témoigne du fait que le
processus intellectuel qui est derrière
la dissertation et fondamentalement
logique c'est à dire rationnelle et puis
il montre aussi que c'est un processus
progressif qui avance étape par étape
vers sa conclusion dans le plan aspect
causes conséquences
les effets sont la conclusion de ce
processus intellectuel ce mot qui est
très utile en dissertation sert lui
aussi en priorité dans la
problématisation et dans la formulation
du plan pour le sujet philosopher c'est
apprendre à mourir qui constitue une
affirmation assez forte
dépourvu de nuances on a par exemple
intérêt à se demander quelles en sont
les limites pour un sujet sur la
mondialisation
on pourrait se demander quelles sont les
limites du phénomène parce que c'est en
réalité une question de degré il y a
toujours eu une forme de mondialisation
et inversement
encore aujourd'hui tout départ
mondialisée loin de là cet exemple
suggère quelques alternatives qui n'ont
toutefois pas le même sens comme
obstacle ou écueils sur le fond
maintenant parler de limites c'est faire
preuve de maturité intellectuelle en
dissertation il faut faire un peu comme
le préconisaient les sceptiques penser
contre l'évidence contre soi même
pratiquer l'alternance des points de vue
[Musique]
le verbe montrer et surtout utile dans
le développement de la dissertation
parce que c'est là que l'on présente les
éléments de réponse à la problématique
pour le sujet et philosopher c'est
apprendre à mourir
par exemple on pourrait commencer un
paragraphe en écrivant l'étymologie du
mot philosophie semble montrer qu'elle
consiste en dernière instance en
l'apprentissage de la mort si le verbe
montré est important c'est parce que la
dissertation est fondamentalement un
exercice d'argumentation bah oui le but
ultime c'est bien de convaincre le
lecteur de la pertinence des éléments de
réponse qu'on avance en effet où
effectivement conviennent tout
particulièrement pour la deuxième phrase
des paragraphes du développement qui
certains et expliqué l'argument
seulement le problème ce n'est pas de
trouver ou utiliser ces boues mais
d'éviter d'en n'inonde et la copie comme
ils sont bien pratiques pour structurer
le propos de chaque paragraphe on a
vraiment tendance à en abuser
la règle que je propose c'est pas plus
d'une occurrence par paragraphe
et puis on peut aussi exprimé la cause
en recourant à un quart parce que
puisque étant donné que voir
éventuellement de fait grâce à ces
alternatives
les phrases ne sont pas empiler
arbitrairement mais toujours inscrite
dans un cheminement de pensée le plus
clair possible
[Musique]
l'adverbe ainsi à lui aussi tendance à
être trop utilisé en dissertation
donc c'est bien de suivre la règle du
une fois maximum par paragraphe les
alternatives permettant d'éviter la
répétition sont par conséquent donc dès
lors où encore de ce fait ainsi sert
généralement faire la fin du paragraphe
dans la mesure où il appelle une forme
de conclusion il est très utile car il
permet de faire des conclusions
partielles c'est-à-dire de poser des
résultats intermédiaires de la réflexion
pour tenir le lecteur par la main ou par
la pâte plus tôt l'adverbe d'opposition
cependant sert surtout à l'intérieur des
paragraphes comme points d'articulation
du raisonnement ou bien dans la
formulation du plan par exemple pour le
sujet philosopher c'est apprendre à
mourir on pourrait formuler les deux
premières parties comme ça si la
philosophie apparaît de prime abord
comme une sagesse visant l'acceptation
de la condition humaine
son évolution historique laisse
cependant penser que la conception posée
par l'énoncé n'épuise pas tous les
possibles de la pratique philosophique
les meilleures alternatives de cependant
son or en revanche néanmoins toutefois
ou encore pourtant elles sont souvent
utilisés en dissertation parce qu elles
en expriment la dimension qu'on appelle
dialectique
ce qui veut dire la structuration
logique de la pensée
en effet l'opposition et le lien logique
le plus courant en dissertation
[Musique]
cet adverbe est lui aussi plutôt peu
utilisé mais il peut servir à la fin de
la problématisation à la fin de chaque
grande partie est peut-être plus
évidemment dans la conclusion il montre
que la réflexion doit aboutir à un
résultat qui dépasse en pertinence en
profondeur et en nuances
les résultats intermédiaires de la
réflexion les alternatives éventuelles
seraient par exemple en définitive au
total ou encore en fin de compte le nom
commun thèse fait assez peur parce qu'il
engage à la présentation de
connaissances précises mais cela peut
être nécessaire pour donner surtout dans
les paragraphes du développement la
preuve d'une certaine maîtrise de
l'histoire des idées notamment en
philosophie culture générale économie
voire peut-être en histoire pour notre
sujet on pourrait par exemple écrire la
thèse de socrate et que la philosophie
est une pratique spirituelle visant en
dernière instance à préparer l'individu
à la mort il est également possible de
parler d'idées de théories de doctrine
de conception de position etc
[Musique]
la préposition selon sir surtout à
introduire des références en priorité
dans les paragraphes du développement de
la dissertation ou éventuellement en
accroche on peut par exemple écrire
selon socrates la philosophie est une
pratique spirituelle servant
fondamentalement à préparer l'individual
abord on pourrait également écrire pour
socrate d'après socrate ou encore se
grattent affirme avant ce que proposait
des références ça on sait généralement
le faire mais on ne sait pas trop
pourquoi
si on utilise des références en
dissertation c'est pour étayer
l'argumentation c'est-à-dire pour donner
plus de force aux éléments de réponses
proposées afin de convaincre le lecteur
[Musique]
ce nom commun n'est pas beaucoup utilisé
en dissertation alors qu'il est vraiment
pratique
c'est déjà une bonne alternative aux
mots aux thèses idées théoriques etc
mais surtout il permet d'articuler
efficacement le raisonnement en prenant
du recul on peut par exemple écrire
cette perspective témoigne eu 2 ou dans
cette perspective pour lier deux phrases
en faisant de la seconde le
développement de la première
enfin le mot perspective peut aussi
servir à indiquer le prisme
intellectuelle dans lequel se développe
le propos en clair on peut zoomer sur le
point de vue d'une discipline en
écrivant par exemple dans une
perspective historique sociologique
économique etc
[Musique]
le mot exemple est plutôt peu utilisé
parce qu'on a peur en l'utilisant
d'abaisser la réflexion à des
considérations vulgaire or un exemple
c'est un bon moyen de rendre
l'argumentation plus pédagogique en
clair de mieux expliquer les choses
du coup le mot exemple peut avoir sa
place dans la problématisation ou à
l'intérieur des paragraphes de
préférence au soutien des références
voire même en tant que référence comme
pour le verbe montré la présence du mot
exemple est la preuve que la
dissertation est un exercice
d'argumentation où la force de chaque
idée dépend en bonne partie de la
manière dont elle est développée comme
pour les termes en effet est ainsi le
risque et d'abuser du verbe semblait
dans une dissertation parce qu'il est
quand même bien commode pour modérer le
propos souvenez-vous de la phrase que
j'ai donnée en exemple pour le mot
numéro 10 l'étymologie du mot
philosophie semble montrer qu'elle
consiste en dernière instance en
l'apprentissage de la mort grâce au
verbe semblait on peut prendre des
pincettes quand on avance une idée ont
fait preuve de maturité intellectuelle
en proposant seulement des éléments de
réponse au problème c'est à dire des
hypothèses c'est important parce que
l'humilité est une composante
fondamentale de la maturité
intellectuelle
on n'est jamais sûr de détenir la vérité
on peut toujours se tromper
alors comme on a tendance à abuser du
verbe semblait on peut aussi modérer le
propos avec les verbes paraître
apparaître pouvoir ou encore plus
généralement avec le mode conditionnel
la phrase que je viens de donner
l'étymologie du mot philosophie semble
montrer qu'elle consiste en dernière
instance en l'apprentissage de la mort
je pourrais la transformer simplement en
l'étymologie du mot philosophie
montrerait qu'elle consiste en dernière
instance en l'apprentissage de la bande
[Musique]
celui ci c'est à vous de le trouver dans
chaque sujet de dissertation
il y à un mot dont l'interprétation
détermine principalement le sens du
sujet et oriente la problématisation
ainsi que la résolution du problème dans
le sujet la philosophie c'est apprendre
à mourir le mot clé et le verbe à
prendre parce que c'est grâce à ce mot
que l'énoncé défini la philosophie comme
un apprentissage
autre exemple dans le sujet du bac l de
philo 2017
suffit-il d'observer pour connaître le
mot clé le verbe suffire dans la mesure
où le problème précis est de savoir si
l'observation est une condition
suffisante de la connaissance
une fois le mot clés identifiés il faut
mettre le paquet dessus non seulement
pour traiter le sujet mais aussi dans la
rédaction
il faut donc le saupoudrer dans la
dissertation jusqu'à 3 4 fois par
paragraphe en faisant ça on donne aux
lecteurs
la très forte impression que la
dissertation tout entière est focalisée
comme un laser sur la résolution du
problème précis du sujet le mot clé lui
ou ses synonymes antonymes ou
expressions comparables est
statistiquement celui qui doit revenir
le plus de fois dans la dissertation
c'est fini tu en as marre bah oui mais
il ya beaucoup de mots des dissertations
si contrairement à aristote vous avez
aimé cette vidéo mettez un pouce bleus
et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la vidéo
suivante
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser un
commentaire
et enfin comme je voulais dit au début
vous pouvez télécharger les
dissertations entièrement rédigé par mes
soins pour les utiliser comme modèle en
cliquant sur le lien qui est dans la
description vous connaissez aristote qui
vient de partir je suis romain et vous
étiez sur mille idées de culture
générale
n'oubliez pas que vous n'avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous
intéresser au meilleur de la pensée et
pour progresser en dissertation
[Musique]